it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week that game that keeps
showing while you're trying to watch the
dota 2 qualifier matches is finally
coming out of beta and on to full
release its heroes of the storm now
Blizzard doesn't consider this a MOBA or
an AR TS because they feel it's
something different with a broader play
style it's got shared experience between
all the players and they've been
referring to it as an online hero
brawler it's been in beta for a long
time but it's not too late to get on
board now here's of the storm is out on
the second next up massive chalice is
making its official debut this week
leaving behind early access you can grab
it on pc but it's a free download if you
got xbox gold you control a nation
growing the numbers by makin babies but
it's not as sweet as you might think you
got to get rid of all those traits like
blood pressure diabetes and anyone in
general showing any signs of weakness
heavy is the head that wears the crown
you take out anyone not fit for breeding
and then put them on the battleground to
roll the dice for their lives you
monster The Escapist finally makes its
way onto ps4 this week after being out
on most everything else you're a
prisoner and you're trying to escape
your cell by working out gathering tools
making friends aidan your escape one
false step and you're sent to solitary
confinement where your game and your
brain are reset if you haven't tried it
yet I would recommend giving it a whirl
orange is the new black it's out on the
second and now it's time to play is that
a game current contender is wander a
non-combat MMO where you play as a tree
and watch turtle swim by yeah walk
around in a forest exploring nature and
enjoying the calm sounds of nature a
great game for people who appreciate
rainforests but don't care for
mosquitoes in the future this is what
all people will play when they want to
remember what trees looked like you can
grab this on the fourth
finally I should probably mention this
absolutely adorable hugging simulator
for pc it's jokingly named hatred
because you walk around finding sad
people and lift up their spirits with
positive messages and a good ol thumbs
up a great game for people who just want
to watch the world beam with happiness
and delight good for you express your
love on the first for further details
visit gamespot com release dates are
based on retailer listings and are
subject to change see you next week